when the community is doing the policing
that's what you get you get P because
and I said that on Twitter the other day
and some leftist get got all up in my
mentions and had a problem and it's like
oh there's all these books and that's
not how it works and Etc but what
they're neglecting to address is that
when you say community policing on the
internet to the vast majority of the
population you're gonna have a
significant portion of UNS
unsophisticated people that are going to
hear that and they're going to think I
have to take care of myself it's my job
to help now whether or not that's the
case it doesn't matter people are going
to think that and they're going to act
like that and that's what you get that's
that's all that you get you're going to
get more of this the fewer cops you have
the fewer security or the less security
you have on the subway system the more
you're gonna get this so this is this is
100 aoc's fault this is Rashida talib's
fault this is uh uh
Ayanna Presley's fault the squad they're
all guilty all of the Democrats that
have been screaming
there the mayor